welcome to Hannity it's going to take
the full hour to get all of this in
we're going to break this down we'll
give you all the news and information
the mob will never give you here's
what's happening we'll start with a
summary the psychotic anti-trump
hysteria it is now completely overtaking
the entire Democratic Party what is
happening is dangerous to this country
it is grossly political will forever
alter how any president in the future as
in his constitutional role as
commander-in-chief will be able to
communicate freely with other world
leaders the world is less safe and
secure tonight as a result of yet the
latest partisan witch hunt we'll break
it all down what we have though at the
root of all this is an irrational hatred
Trump rage it is all this party the
Democratic Party now stands for today
and I will predict tonight they have
done Donald Trump a huge favor it will
all backfire and blow up right in their
face speaker a name only Nancy Pelosi
she was forced to cave to a radical base
and announced that official impeachment
inquiry against President Trump by the
way that's what we've been living
through for the last three years so make
no mistake this has nothing to do with
Ukraine this has nothing to do with
collusion this has nothing to do with
high crimes and misdemeanors because
there are none this has everything to do
with the left's unyielding unhealthy
what is an obsessive compulsive hatred a
president Trump they can't accept that
he won that was November of 2016 they're
still there and I think they even doubt
they can beat him at the ballot box
which is why they are trying to do this
now you know he occupies every single
conscious thought in their minds it's
like the moment they wake up to the
moment they fall asleep Donald Trump
lives in the heads of these psychotic
Democrats and their friends and the
media mob it kind of lives there
rent-free every hour of every second of
every day it is a sickness but now it's
officially hurting the country as it
rules their lives so what are the
grounds for impeachment
according to Pelosi today it's all
about president Trump's phone call with
his Ukrainian counterpart keep in mind
president trump ordered the transcript
before nancy pelosi's big announcement
that it's going to be released that will
happen tomorrow I have numerous sources
telling me tonight that the only thing
the president discussed with the new
president of Ukraine well was what he
ran on which is ending corruption which
the new Ukrainian president pledged to
do and by the way does anyone care at
all that our president is being spied on
again we'll get into a lot more of that
tonight what foreign leader it's
happened we have transcripts now the
president's conversations with prime
ministers and presidents
well what foreign leader will ever again
be willing to freely talk to a US
president and we'll have more on that in
a moment but according to reports the
whistleblower complaint about the call
that will be released by the end of the
week but the radical socialist Democrats
they just couldn't wait another second I
don't care that they haven't seen the
transcript of the call they don't care
that the so-called whistleblower was
never a whistleblower and this is
second-hand information or hearsay had
no direct knowledge of what happened on
that call they don't care that Ukrainian
officials that's right and others that
actually know what happened on the call
have all VM Utley denied the so-called
whistleblowers accusation of pressure or
any quid pro quo and multiple sources
confirming again to me tonight that
there is no quid pro quo but according
to Nancy Pelosi it doesn't even need to
be a quid pro quo in order to impeach
what's this insanity unfolding or other
shall we say
candidates from the future more sense in
terms of the Constitution you said but
this one is the most understandable by
the public and it's really important to
know this it is there is no requirement
there be a quid pro quo in the
conversation that the president brings
up he wants them to investigate
something that's to the end of his
political opponent but that is
self-evident that it is not right I hope
like a dirty Russian dossier oh you only
care if you can blood and Trump and tell
them what i mereloc more flexibility
after the election
well what about oh let's just offer
Iranian mullahs that want to blow us up
and well wipe Israel and the u.s. off
the map we'll just give them a hundred
and fifty bucks those are the
conversations they have all right Nancy
hold your vote if you're so worried
let's do this let's see how far the
radical Democratic Party is willing to
take this baseless political stunt I say
to the speaker well in name only order
the call call the roll Nancy I want
every one of your Democrats on the
record I dare you to do it now I'm sure
the real Speaker that would be
Alexandria Castillo Cortez will demand
it and they also predict you're probably
going to buckle because you know your
jobs on the line and you are not in
control of your caucus at all so let's
get this on the record let's see
Democratic lawmakers you know ones from
oh look right there those are all
Democratic lawmakers that one districts
that Donald Trump one let's get them on
the record do they have the courage to
do that
well they support impeachment over
nothing will they trash the will of
their own constituents will they
continue to waste time taxpayer money
over drains political folly that will go
nowhere in the US Senate and by the way
congressman golden congressman Maloney
congressman McAdams Congressman Suzie
lead and all the rest of them there what
do you say 31 members of Congress must
now come out of hiding we want to know
where you stand on your leader of your
party do you answer to your constituents
or are you joining the squad of radical
socialists that wanna ban cows and
planes and get rid of the lifeblood of
our economy oil and gas and tax America
into oblivion and destroy the the
greatest wealth creating system ever
designed by man and by the way do you
want that as much as you want to destroy
President Trump because frankly I have
no faith that you will make the right
decision after all your so-called leader
Nancy Pelosi is now totally and
completely controlled by a couple of
freshman lawmakers in Congress and a
chairwoman who doesn't know the
difference between Crimea and Korea this
is the state of this new radical extreme
democratic socialist party everything's
going to be free for three long years
they have put this country through hell
and they haven't lifted a single finger
nothing to make this country a more
secure country a better place with more
jobs more opportunity more economic
growth what are their plans to boost
American industry and create jobs where
are their plans to keep Americans safe
and secure where are their plans to
solve the murder crisis in America's
biggest cities like Chicago and all the
other democratic run cities for decades
that are experiencing horrible schools
horrible violence because the answer is
nowhere to be found that is what today
is about
because Democrats they have now spent
three years hyperventilating every
second minute hour of every day about
one anti-trump hoax after another Russia
Russia Russia stormy stormy stormy and
Peach and Peach and Peach Oh collusion
collusion tax returns tax returns
obstruction obstruction Ukraine Ukraine
how does any of this rage help any
American in three long years you have
dragged this country and this president
a duly elected president through the mud
and we're about to see all of the
corrupt dealings and handling
Oh intelligence and all the lying and
all the conspiracy theories that were
peddled by the corrupt media mob in this
country and then to top it off now
no world leader will ever want to have a
not honest phone conversation with any
President of the United States is that
good for our safety and security I would
think it's a good thing that we have
enumerated powers in the Constitution
and we have yes one commander in chief
at a time and I can't think of a single
time in the history of this great
country before Donald Trump where
presidents phone calls with other world
leaders will repeatedly hacked into and
leaked to the public now what happens
left and right who leaked the contents
of the president's call with the
Australian prime minister who leaked the
whistleblower well that's not a
whistleblower claims about the call with
the Ukrainian president Trust has now
forever been destroyed every world
leader that gets on the phone with the
u.s. president they're going to say oh
this is probably going to be leaked one
day that will not be an honest
conversation that could potentially
advance peace in the world
and yet every House Democrat all they
seem to care about is their insatiable
urge and compulsion impeach Trump that
is why tonight the real leader of the
Democratic Party is very pleased take a
look I think that we all you know many
of us especially from districts that are
experiencing the brunt of the
president's decisions are have been
feeling a sense of urgency around this
but I think the development around the
whistleblower I think these developments
are exactly you know where we need to be
all right tonight if you care about the
sanctity of your vote if you really care
about real issues that affect this
country
let's see president Trump created well
almost 7 million new jobs over the past
three years almost seven million fewer
Americans are on food stamps we now have
the best employment situation since 1969
Oh record low unemployment for African
Americans Asian Americans Hispanic
Americans women in the workplace youth
unemployment for the first time in 75
the mob will never tell you this in the
media we are now a net exporter of
energy and our completely energy
independent which by the way it's time
to send Washington a message that means
the straits of hormuz are less
strategically geopolitically important
than they've ever been to this country
what happens in the Middle East we don't
necessarily need to get involved in
entanglements that we otherwise would
have in the past you might want to tell
your representative you don't pay them
to spend every second of every day every
year after year hour after hour trying
to destroy a duly elected president
that's what elections are for you can
tell them you're done with this BS
you're done with the political games
you're done with the never-ending witch
hunts and president Trump was duly
elected by we the American people in
spite of deep state efforts - oh let's
see spy on them and use Russian lies or
to quote the New York Times likely
Russian disinformation from the get-go
and that would be Hillary's dirty
dossier after well the deep state saved
her from going to jail that would be the
Espionage Act and by the way I wouldn't
try it at home what Hillary did if you
have emails that are subpoenaed I
wouldn't delete them
I wouldn't acid wash your hard drive
with bleach pit and I wouldn't bust up
your device's with hammers because then
you'll be charged with obstruction of
justice something they protected her
from it's been three years now it's time
for them to get over they lost
try and beat Donald Trump at the ballot
box I don't think you believe you can
and by the way that won't happen if they
nominate sleepy creepy crazy Uncle Joe
303 302 the left's ukraine hysteria they
have now done America a favor because
now Joe Biden is finally getting exposed
and some richly deserved attention for
his own Ukrainian scandal should shock
the conscience of every American